hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions here's a fun
problem I found online
this unusual shape has three right
angles as marked also its side lengths
are four three four and five the
question is what is the value of the
last sides length which is marked as X
in the diagram pause if you'd like to
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so briefly mention the solution I'm
going to present is very similar to
another video where you had to solve for
X the length of this square side we're
going to use a little outside the box
thinking so in our diagram the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
draw it a little bit to scale this will
just help in our presentation now let's
connect these two points we're going to
figure out this distance but how can we
do that well let's focus just on these
three sides now let's rotate them so
it'll be a little easier to understand
the distance between the two endpoints
I'm going to join the three side with
the five side and then I'm going to
bring the four side to the left we have
a right triangle where one leg is four
and the other leg is three plus five
which equals eight we can solve for its
hypotenuse as the square root of the sum
of the squares of its sides this will be
the square root of 4 squared plus 8
squared so now let's go back to our
original diagram so we know this is the
same distance from endpoint to endpoint
and we're going to bring it back to our
unusual shape and now let's just focus
on this right triangle what is the value
of x in this right triangle well we know
that the length of the hypotenuse will
be the square root of 4 squared plus x
squared and it's also equal to the
square root of 4 squared plus 8 squared
therefore X is equal to 8 and that's our
answer I know there are other ways to
solve this problem but I thought this
one was very fun and I wanted to share
it with you thanks for watching and for
making mind your decisions one of the
best channels on YouTube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]